Speaker 1: School in Florida and in most
parts of Florida started right around
August 25th. Twenty third, et cetera, including in
Miami-Dade County, 15 educators are already dead
in the first ten days. Now, importantly, you know,
we're not saying they all caught it at school. In
fact, some of them probably caught it before
school started. But these are not particularly
auspicious numbers for the entire school year.
Here's a report from NBC six in Miami-Dade County,
15 staffers of the Miami-Dade County Public School
District have died from covid in the past 10 days.
Sonia Diaz, a spokesperson for several unions,
confirmed the number of deaths to NBC six.
One of the educators that lost their life to covid
was Abe Coleman, a teacher for more than 30 years.
Coleman was also a mentor and site director
for the 5000 Role Models of Excellence program.
He helped shape the lives of hundreds of young
men over the years in the organization that
mentors minority men. On Tuesday, Coleman
lost his life to covid at the age of 55
55. Officials haven't released the identities
of the other teachers or staff members, and a
Miami-Dade County public school spokesperson said
the district doesn't release the cause of death
for employees or students. This is this is
the disaster on so many levels. First of all,
you've got Rhonda Santurce in Florida saying no
masks and schools, no mask mandates in schools.
Many schools are just straight up going against
Rhonda Sanderson saying we're wearing masks in
schools. On a practical level, what's worse for
school kids wearing a mask or the trauma of their
teacher dying? Think about that for a second. I'm
trying to think back. If a teacher of mine I liked
basically all my teachers in elementary school
and the class was close to many of these teachers.
If a teacher of mine had
died during the school year,
it's hard to imagine actually what that would have
done. I remember when one teacher was out for a
month with heart issues and we had a substitute
and it was really stressful for the class. I
remember when a different teacher, I think it was
in seventh grade, fainted and the EMTs came in.
It was really stressful. And here we're talking
about 15 educators, some of them teachers,
just dying during the first 10 days of the
school year. And the alternative, of course, is
not that it would have prevented every every
death. Some of these teachers got it outside of
school. But when you see this seriously happening,
how do you say, well, let's just not wear masks?
The masks really aren't a big deal for these
kids. So tomorrow we'll get into in more detail
what really seems to be an uncertain future for
this pandemic. And we'll get into the details
of why, but not a good start. My sister was
telling me on day two, someone tested positive at
her school. She's a senior in high school. And,
um, maybe maybe the details don't don't really
matter. But the point is, it's hard to imagine
this is going to go particularly smoothly. And if
schools aren't even requiring the kids wear masks,
it's going to go even worse. We'll have more
coverage of this on our Instagram Findus The David
Pakman Show. Find me on Instagram at David Pakman